Hi, my name is Rameen Hunnery, and I'm here to talk to you today about my clone of EMEX
and EMEX list, but that I've written in Scheme so far.
So I am an EMEX enthusiast since 2017, currently employed as a full stack developer, mostly
working with Python and JavaScript, although my true love is functional programming, especially
Haskell and Scheme.
I started learning Scheme about two years ago, and for the past year I've been working
on a project that I am tentatively calling Gypsum, naming things as hard.
That's not a great name, I'm open to suggestions, but yes, this is the project in which I am
trying to write EMEX list interpreter in Scheme.
But there are many clones already of EMEX, you've probably heard of Edwin, Jad, Jad, Jove,
Lem, MG, Y, Zile, Edwin itself is also written in Scheme, MIT Scheme.
These only clone the key bindings of EMEX and not EMEX list itself.
The only alternative to GNU EMEX that I'm aware of is XEMEX, which is a fork of
GNU EMEX.
Most people don't use EMEX for the key bindings, I mean this is anecdotally speaking, but the
people who I've talked to, I would say don't use EMEX for the key bindings, they use it
really more because of the power of EMEX list.
EMEX is as powerful as any system shell, perhaps even more powerful, system shells like
BASH.
The reason why it's so powerful is because there's a good programming language, which you can
use to control everything on your system, you can control processes, you can load and save
files, you can create files, you can configure things, you can capture the output of processes
and buffers, you can filter text through buffers, and a good programming language is what you
need in order to do all of this.
One big goal of this project is to try to stick as closely as possible to the R7RS standard
scheme definition, that is the latest scheme standard R7, and this is just because I want
my project to work on many scheme implementations, not just GAL.
Although GAL certainly is the reference implementation, so another goal is to be able to run any init.el,
so you can take your existing init.el and run it in my program without significant changes,
that's one of my goals in the end, I should be able to do that.
A lot of people invest significant time in their configs, and it's kind of disruptive if
you want to change editors, not be able to use your emax list config, and so I think a useful
emax clone would be able to clone emax list, well enough that you can run your init.el,
and so overall, why am I doing this, that's just because I like this scheme programming language,
I love it simplicity, and it's power, it's extremely well thought out language, and
it's one of those languages where you can understand the entire language from top to bottom,
you can read the entire specification, and then understand it yourself, it's like computers
I grew up with when I was a kid, they were all very simple computers in the late 80s, early
90s, and back then, theoretically an engineer could understand the entire system at the software
level, all the way down to the circuit level, you can't do that nowadays, and so nowadays
my computer is not really a physical computer anymore, it's the scheme language standard
itself, that is the core of all of the computation for me, and I would like to use it as more than
just an academic curiosity, it was originally designed for teaching at MIT, but it's found
to use an industry, and the RSA and RSA standard is still relatively new, it's over 10 years
old at this point, but hasn't, I mean the scheme ecosystem itself is already fairly small,
and there's still, I don't think has been a whole lot of adoption of RSA and RSA quite
yet, kind of a shame, so it's like a project like this, a very large scale, kind of a killer
app like project where you're developing a text editor, and perhaps even an integrated
development environment in the scheme, I think would be very useful, just even as a study
of what can this language do, and just overall there seems to be a lot of interest in Guile-based
EMAX, and well maybe a scheme-based EMAX, but Guile in particular, there has been talk
of changing EMAX-Lisp or the core of the EMAX-Lisp over to Guile, for about 30 years or so, talks
originally in the early mid-90s, there were discussions between Richard Stalman, Tom
Lord and Audrey Jaffer, they considered actually replacing EMAX-Lisp with scheme, 1999, and going
for about 10 years, someone named Ken Rayburn, actually started a project where he started
writing EMAX in Guile, my project is very similar to this, here's a quote from his webpage
which is still up, even though it hasn't been updated in 15 years, this project that I have
started is for converting GNU EMAX to Guile as its programming language, support for EMAX-Lisp,
it will continue to exist of course, but it may be through translation and/or interpretation,
the list of engine itself may no longer be the core of the program, and this is my goal as well.
In 2010, Andy Wingo and Ludovic Cortez took a maintenance of the Guile project, from
2009 to 2011, the first EMAX-Lisp interpreter was already being implemented in Guile, and
even to this day, this EMAX-Lisp interpreter ships with Guile, and so this was happening
while Andy Wingo took control of the project.
In 2011, so shortly after Andy Wingo took control of the project, Guile 2.0 was released,
and also in 2011, in the summertime, someone named Robin Templeton, I believe it was Google
Summer of Code Project, started actually trying to incorporate live Guile, that's the Guile
interpreter as a loadable library linking it to the EMAX executable, and then providing
some built-in functions in EMAX that allows you to call the EMAX, or call the Scheme interpreter,
the Guile Scheme interpreter, from EMAX, and so it's not like a wrapper around the
wrapper like Geyser or Slime. It's actually the whole Scheme interpreter loaded into
your EMAX process, and that means your EMAX will have the ability to actually load compiled
Scheme programs and actually run them and share memory with EMAX-Lisp processes, and
well, Robin Templeton will explain all of this they're presenting today, and I'm very
excited to actually see their presentation. They'll explain everything.
So let's see, moving on, 2020, someone named Vasily Shiniderman, not sure how he pronounced
that, published an overview called the State of EMAX-Lisp on Guile. Let's see if I have
that here. Yep, it's this page right here. He goes into detail about who has done what
so far, and what can you do in Guile with EMAX-Lisp so far, and so on. Like, what is the state
of the project overall? And so, let's speak of the devil, and he would go on social media.
So, 2020 to present, Guile EMAX is dead, so there's GCC EMAX now. There's EMAX-Lisp is
now has its own JIT compiler, and it seems like over the past few years EMAX-Lisp has kind
of moved off into the direction of becoming its own programming language in its own right,
and it is decidedly commonlisp flavored. It is very similar to commonlisp, and that seems
to be the direction that it's headed now, and I don't know if there's really any interest
anymore amongst the Guile, or the EMAX-Lisp containers, of continuing with a Guile-based EMAX.
But as far as I know, there's still a lot of interest in community amongst scheme and
Lisp and EMAX users who are interested in maybe continuing to try to get Guile to become
the core of EMAX, or if not, you know, what Rod and Templeton has been doing, at least
trying to get Guile something, a language, a first class support language in EMAX.
So that's enough talking. Let me just show you what I have so far. The GUI is barely working,
as I have very little experience with GTK, or a G-Object Interjection. It's very difficult
to debug, so it's very slow to develop any crash at sea level, and produces no stack traces.
So far, most of the crashes that I've experienced are due to simple mistakes, like passing
wrong data type. So far, not a whole lot of need for GDB, or rebuilding all GTK, G-Live,
and so on, with the debugging symbols. But yes, still development has been very slow. I'm
learning as I go. I've chosen to use Guile GI as the foundation for the GUI. Let me just
load it up quick here, load in Guile scheme. And this will launch the GUI. I also happen to
have a REPL that runs in a separate thread and submits any form that you type to be evaluated
inside of the running GUI environment. But let me just, you can just type stuff. So hello.
Well, and of course, there is, as you can see, it's not quite rendering correctly. This message
is thing here. That should be over here, obviously. I haven't been able to figure out how to get
those little details down. But yeah, you can do Alt-Column, and you get your Reval, and you
can just evaluate, like, it's an E-Mex, or it's a Scheme-specific thing, like Import, Serfee
1, and let's see, do Iota 20, for example. And so that is the procedure that iterates and
produces some 20 elements of a list, or you can do something like, let's see, string
append, hello, with space world. Any other result, and so on. And, you know, Scheme allows
you to return multiple values. So what I have done here is just every value is captured
in a list, and prints all of the return values in a list. So for procedure returns, no values,
you get an empty list. And that's that. It's still quite buggy. So if like, here's a bug
that I can reproduce fairly consistently, I can, yeah, if you do, there seems to be a problem
with a widget being freed, so it will crash. I'm trying to solve that, hopefully, before
this presentation goes live. Let's see here. The E-MexLisp parser is based on Gile E-MexLisp,
so the Gile E-MexLisp interpreter that is, that ships with Gile, that is what I am using.
I've actually copied and pasted the source code from the Gile source base into my own
project, so that I can iterate it on it more quickly. And I've already had to make some
modifications to the E-MexLisp interpreter in Gile. So here's the evaluator. I've actually
already modified the parser and the lecture a little bit. And it's at least able to parse
all of the subar.el program, the E-MexLisp program. It can actually load that, but not evaluate
it, or parsed, but not evaluated. Read, not a bell. I have, or by the time this goes live,
I will have submitted a patch upstream. And that's another goal of this project, incidentally,
is that anything that we can contribute to Gile and anything, any built-in functions
that we can implement, I would like to, for this project, I would like to try and contribute
upstream to Gile. The E-MexLisp interpreter is not working well, unfortunately. So this copy,
this is the copy of the code base from this commit in particular. And well, I can't get
it working. I can't actually get the non-copy, the actual built-in version of the E-MexLisp interpreter
to work properly quite yet. So let me quick go to, what is this here? Gile, E-Lisp. So suppose
you have this E-Val E-Lisp procedure here, and it takes an E-Lisp environment, and then
it evaluates an expression in that environment, and evaluates to a value. So this is the standard
way of doing it in Gile. If you can see here, you've got this expression, compile expression.
This is like E-Val. And so I actually trying to load this. So let's do load. Let's see here.
This is, no, I'm going to import Gypsum back-end Gile, E-Lisp. And if I actually want to do this,
so E-Lisp, first of all, it says it failed, because there's an unbound variable E-Lisp,
you don't know what it's talking about. There's no such variable in any of my programs. I have no
idea what's going on here. You can try to run the E-Val E-Lisp on some simple form like plus 1, 2,
and it gives you this exception. This works. This is the same issue that I have with all of the
every version of the E-Max Lisp interpreter in Gile. I can get it to work with this big L mode,
so I can actually do plus 1 and 2 here. I can do Prink, like, 2 here. That all works fine.
It gives me, for some reason, a stack trace here.
And yeah, so it's a bit, it's not well documented. The code base is fairly old. As I said,
it was developed around 2011, and it's fairly opaque, and I have not been able to figure out how to get
E-Max Lisp in Gile working smoothly. So I have started writing my own E-Max Lisp interpreter,
and gypsum, E-Lisp, GileTest.esky. It's not entirely ready. I can show you some of the tests, at least.
Here is a simple E-Max Lisp program that you can evaluate. You got ProgN,
set QA to 3, set QB to 5, set QC to the sum of A and B, return C.
And this, at least, works correctly. As you can see here, the result is 8,
but the Lisp service mandate is enough. Completed yet. Lots of work left to do there.
Yeah. So, in the time I have left, I guess, I can just talk a little bit about what my plans are for
the future. So, I would like to begin by evaluating or, you know, actually loading the sub-R.E-L
into my E-Max Lisp interpreter. I actually have tests set up for that as well, so I can actually
select any form I want from sub-R.E-L, and I can just run this through my interpreter and test to see
if everything is working. Once I get that far. Let me just say that this is my formal appeal to the
community for help on this project. E-Max Lisp has 1393 built-in functions. I could never implement
that many functions on my own, so if this project is going to be useful to anybody in any reasonable
amount of time, I'm going to need help. And I know that there are people out there who are very
interested in a Guile-based E-Max, and so if you're watching this, please feel free to contact me on
social media or over email. My job, the way I see it, is if there's enough interest, and I do get a
lot of people interested in starting to contribute. My job will be to document the building and testing
process and make sure that it is as easy as possible to contribute code to this project. I want to
document the system architecture, I'll write blog posts, I'll do videos on peer tube, explaining how
our thing works, and I will prioritize which built-in functions I think are probably going to be the
most necessary, the most essential to get the interpreter running, and then find low-hanging fruit
functions that are easy for people to implement as a good introduction to getting them started on
contributing to the project. And then of course I will take responsibility myself of
making sure that we can get the E-List interpreter to the point where it can run the E-Max regression tests,
and these are the test suites that are used to test E-MaxList itself in the E-Max code base.
And so ERT is itself written in E-MaxList, and so I think if we implement enough of the built-in
functions to be able to run ERT, then we can actually start using the GNU E-Max regression tests
to test our own interpreter, our own E-Max clone. And of course I'll make sure that there's at least
one usable GUI. I'm currently working on Guile GI and GTK. It would be great to have
and curses based, you know, ANSI terminal-based, something that works in your terminal emulator.
And yeah, it would be great if someday soon, hopefully, we get enough done that you can actually
contribute a patch to this project from within the gypsum editor itself. That was going to do an
overview, but that would be for more of an hour-long presentation. So I'm out of time. I guess the
last thing I should quickly say is there's no matter object protocol in this project, I think that's
a little bit too difficult to port to various schema limitations. So I've created a substitute,
which I'm calling functional lenses, which is inspired by the Haskell project of the same name.
Everything in this project is based on functional lenses.
Yeah, also in a lot of work into the chemax data structure, the point being that I think I have
a pretty good foundation here upon which we can build even though there isn't an actual, there isn't
a lot done in the actual prototype itself, not yet anyway. But I made sure to get the fundamentals
down from the beginning. And so I think we have something a solid foundation on which to build.
So I'm going to conclude it there. And here's my contact details. Like I said, this is a project I'm
appealing to the community of all people who are interested in Gyla and EMAX to help contribute
to this project. I see myself as just getting the ball rolling again, taking off from the work
that Ken Rayburn left behind with my own, you know, from the ground implementation though.
So yeah, contact me, email. You can take a look at my blog where I talk about what I have done.
My source code, the code for this project is up on Codeberg. And the presentation,
this presentation, the homepage for this presentation, you can find more details there.
And yeah, oh, I'm on activity pub as well. So my handle is,
my mean how-90001@fe.discrood.org. And I'm on every day. So yeah, please feel free to contact me
if you're interested. And thank you for your attention.
[BLANK_AUDIO]